let's get right into audience questions
I missed answering questions during the
vacation glad we're back into it first
one is from Jake Jake says hey David is
the user deep hackman on chess comm
really you and are you really that bad
at chess sadly the answer to both
questions is yes I do play on chess calm
and I am deep Ackman there and yeah I
mean I'm relatively new to playing chess
with any regularity and I'm not that
good and what's really crazy to me is
that just from playing like two or three
months consistently and reading up a
little bit about chess when I now play
with just random people who don't really
play off and like you know how sometimes
you're somewhere and there's a chess
board and you'll say let's play a game
those people I just absolutely crush
like even just some regular playing I
end up destroying the person who just
doesn't ever really play and yet still
my rating is like between 800 and 1100
depending on like what format I'm
playing in and anybody who's even like
an intermediate beginner absolutely
crushes and destroys me so I'm gonna
keep at it I enjoy it but yes I am NOT
that good currently yeah I don't play
myself but I feel like it's one of those
things where you can jump the learning
curve hmm initially and in a very short
amount of time I'm sure you get better
than like your contemporaries but
eventually you start dealing with the
people who are like masters at this
thing and it's gonna be a very long time
before you can beat them well listen I'm
not dealing with any masters for me I'm
talking about someone who's like ranked
14 rated 1400 absolutely crushes me but
I think you're right in that once you
understand that you know moving a random
edge pawn up one space as an a1 square
as an opening move statistically is not
going to lead to that many wins and you
sort of started to develop an
understanding for like here's the basic
opening moves that you should at least
be doing that already
against someone who literally doesn't
ever play puts you at a big advantage
but again anyone who plays slightly more
regularly than you knows how to defend
against all that yeah
are you able to now think like three or
four moves ahead because of course
that's what you have to do i can mostly
identify a couple moves ahead basically
and not often accurately but at least i
can think a couple moves ahead often
wrong but at least i'm doing the
thinking so yeah hey listen if anyone
wants to challenge me on chess calm i am
deep Ackman there we can connect a chess
game
maybe we'll keep it on your table we'll
connect that to like a membership pitch
drive yeah where every time we get like
a new patron we move a chess piece one
one slot that's a possibility the other
one is that we could also do some kind
of telethon of sorts where donors get to
play me in a game of chess on chess calm
because I think you can challenge
specific people so I don't know if
anyone cares to see me lose games of
chess to people in our audience because
I know that I know from having tweeted a
couple of chess questions that there are
people in our audience who are way
better than I am at chess that's
something I don't know what I don't know
if there's really any future for doing
check it gives me a check very very good
all right thanks Jake appreciate it